what is the stock exchange and how does
it work the stock exchange is nothing
more than a giant globally networked end
to organized marketplace where everyday
huge sums of money are moved back and
forth in total over 60 trillion euros a
year are traded more than the value of
all goods and services of the entire
world economy however it's not apples or
secondhand toothbrushes that are traded
on this marketplace but predominantly
securities securities are rights to
assets mostly in the form of shares a
share stands for a share in the company
but why are shares traded at all well
first and foremost the value of a share
relates the company behind it if we
think of the value of the company in
terms of a pizza the bit of the overall
science of the lead set the bigger every
piece is if for example Facebook is able
to greatly increase its profits with a
new business model the size of the
company's Pizza will also increase and
as a result so will the value of its
shares this is of course great for the
shareholders a share which perhaps used
to be worth 38 euros could now be worth
a whole 50 euros when it's sold this
represents a profit of 12 euros per
share but what does Facebook came from
this the company can raise funds by
selling the shares and invest or expand
its business Facebook for example has
earned 16 billion dollars from its
listing on the stock exchange the
trading of shares though is frequently a
game of chance no one can say which
company will perform well and which will
not if a company has a good reputation
investors will back it a company with a
poor reputation or poor performance will
have difficulty selling its shares
unlike a normal market in which goods
can be touched and taken home on the
stock exchange only virtual goods are
available
they appear in the form of share prices
and tables on monitors such share prices
can rise or fall within seconds
shareholders therefore have to act
quickly in order not to miss an
opportunity
even a simple rumor can result in a
demand for a share falling fast
regardless of the real value of the
company of course the opposite is also
possible if a particularly large number
of people buy weak shares because they
see for example great potential behind
an idea their value will rise as a
result in particular young companies can
benefit from this even though their
sales might be falling they can generate
cash by placing their shares in the best
case scenario this will result in their
idea being turned into reality in the
worst case scenario this will result in
a speculative bubble with nothing more
than hot air and as in the case with
bubbles at some point they will burst
the value of germany's biggest Fetty
companies is summarized in what's known
as the dax share index the Dex curve
shows how well or poorly these major
companies and thereby the economy as a
whole are performing at the present time
stock exchanges in other countries also
have their own indices and all of these
markets together create a globally
networked marketplace
[Music]
you